Alex Karp of Palantir was apparently
spotted in Israel today and Alex Karp
now expected to also
be the first major investor into a new
defense company formed by the Ukrainian
defense minister who got the boot in
July.
So, what's going on here and how could
you potentially play this and what is
Kratos, the stock Kratos, Ktos,
have anything to do with all of this?
Well, let's try to put all of this
together. So, first according to the
Kyiv Independent uh
the defense minister, former defense
minister of Ukraine is offering drone
technology to the United States in
exchange for Patriot missiles. In other
words, Ukraine wants to be the
manufacturing ground for drone
technology that the United States can
utilize
in exchange for Patriot missiles. Now,
there's been some talk uh about how
companies like L3 Harris and Raytheon do
not want to license their technology to
Ukraine for Ukraine to manufacture these
American weapons cheaper because they're
worried about IP theft. Of course, if
you man- manufacture all of this in the
United States, it's going to be a lot
slower than if you manufacture it
overseas. So, some people are arguing
that these legacy defense contractors
are, you know, to the detriment of
American lives trying to hold on to
their intellectual property because it
could just be manufactured cheaper in
Ukraine. And so, now Ukraine's like,
"Fine, don't give us your IP. We'll just
develop new technology ourselves." And
so, now you've got Fedorov who is
seeking US investments for a new defense
technology fund and offering to help
Washington develop drone capabilities in
exchange for Patriot missile
interceptors.
So, we'll manufacture your drones. You
give us Patriots. This apparently in
this uh Financial Times interview here
where they're calling it not exactly a
classic venture fund. Instead, we're
writing this new history of war and a
lot of it's going to have to do with
drones. Not only high-speed interceptors
to counter Russia's new jet-powered
attack drones. We'll talk about those in
just a moment and what Kratos has to do
with all of this.
Uh but also uh
how to potentially manufacture better
drones ourselves that we could use
either, you know, in partnership with uh
Ukraine or even just ourselves given
that we might end up needing them uh to
defend against Iranian attacks in the
Middle East, especially over what's
happened within the last 24 hours. He
identified three initial priorities for
the fund: battlefield robotics to reduce
the reliance on manpower,
cheap, high-speed interceptors for
drones,
uh and low-cost AI-enabled
missiles.
Well, sounds a little little freakish.
Uh but anyway, he was the uh Ukraine's
Russia Ukraine's youngest defense
minister until he was sacked after just
6 months in office, and now he's going
to lead this uh essentially venture
capital fund to go hunt for uh funding,
and it looks like Alex Karp is uh biting
hook, line, and sinker.
First major new investor in the defense
company that uh this defense minister is
putting together, former defense
minister is putting together. Uh Russia
now also reportedly increasingly using
jet-powered drones, which can travel up
to 600 km/h, more than three times as
fast as a piston drone. Uh this is
definitely something to pay attention to
given that if we end up having drones
that previously were the uh Shahed, it's
pronounced apparently, uh drones that
travel about 130 mph, these drones are
expected to go somewhere around 300 mph.
So, you have this massive boost in
speed, still nowhere near as fast as a
uh jet-powered ballistic missile, which
could, you know,
fly in the range of 7 to 10 times Mach,
which, you know, we're talking thousands
of miles per hour.
That
being different from these, but these
drones, you know, missiles are obviously
going much faster aerodynamically or
otherwise, these drones traveling
three times as fast as the usual
propeller-powered drone, creating
problems in Ukraine because Ukraine is
now having issues actually intercepting
these because they're so freaking fast.
So, in other words, the attack weaponry
is developing faster than the defense
machinery is.
Uh uh
Whatever, you know what I'm saying. It
is uh so, the defenses are growing. Uh
and that's where Kratos actually comes
into play. And so, we're going to do a
fundamental analysis on Kratos to see
exactly what they're developing and how
this applies to exactly this race that's
going on. But first, I want you to see
some of these jet-powered drones, some
of this footage here by uh Radio Free
Europe.
Take a look at this because in my
opinion, when when you see these
jet-powered drones compared to the slow
ones that we've seen, those Shaheds,
you know, we've all seen those videos on
Twitter or whatever before, take a look
at how fast these puppies are.
Crazy.
>> These drones are commonly known in
Ukraine as Shaheds. In Russia, they're
called Geran 2. But in recent weeks,
this drone has taken a backseat. An
upgraded version known as Geran 4 now
has a jet engine and the ability to be
controlled online.
>> It's crazy.
>> This Ukrainian air defense crew operates
Soviet-made Osa surface-to-air missile
system. It is still protecting Ukrainian
skies from enemy targets.
>> So, this is the the big issue here is
this is an older school, more
traditional defense weaponry. This is
where you're firing projectiles at these
drones to take them down. They interview
this person, they talk about how, you
know, important they are to taking down
these propeller drones, but how it's
becoming harder to take down these
jet-powered drones. And that's actually
where companies are now trying to come
up with multiple different uh styles of
intercepting
uh this jet-powered drone technology or
really any kind of drone technology. Uh
some of these
options uh that are being developed uh
include uh radio frequencies. Uh so,
trying to just jam these uh these
drones, which is sort of your more
classic kind of intercept style. Uh but,
then you've also got the potential uh
for
um
how how should we call it? Uh we've got
this written down here. Let's go Let's
go to exactly what we wrote down.
The systems. Here they are. Yeah, I've
got my little segment right here. You've
got
jamming, which is your radio frequency
tool. You've also got high-powered
microwaves. So, a burst of microwave
energy, basically, to take down entire
swarm in the form of a cone. I think of
this as your area of effect kind of
attack, like in World of Warcraft, uh
single target versus multi-target. So,
in the form of a cone, Raytheon
currently produces the PHASER system in
this. So, you've got radio frequency
jamming, you've got
microwave radiation, and then you've got
directed energy, which would sort of be
like a single-shot laser.
And the idea here is that
these defenses are much cheaper tools
than sending a missile, like what you're
seeing or we just saw in that video,
like, firing a rocket after these
drones. It's going to cost you a $30,000
rocket to $3 million per interceptor,
like a Patriot interceptor. Whereas with
these directed energy shots, you're
really using about 1 to $10 worth of
electricity
to fire these directed energy weapons.
You can see here in the Kratos
uh earnings call, Q4 is important
because of this program, we got funding
for it. The Department of Energy is
looking for companies to help secure
nuclear assets.
They're developing a mobile and
transportable system where Kratos is the
prime contractor responsible for the
entire system working, including the
directed energy weapons. Where the goal
is to intercept these drones at a low
low cost, and these technologies are
just now ramping and ramping into 2027.
So, if we go back here for a moment and
just jump forward, take a listen to this
just for a moment.
>> intercept. publicly
>> It is publicly known that the Russian
military is currently using several
versions of jet-powered attack drones,
the Geran 3, Geran 4, and Geran 5. The
first adaptation of Iran's Shahed 238
drone is a transitional model with a
flight speed of around 300 km/h.
Ukrainian drone defense units have shot
down these drones repeatedly, but the
later versions of the Geran are
significantly faster than Ukrainian
interceptors.
>> Right, and that's the key problem right
there. Is the speed. And the question
is, those drones are being manufactured
in Russia
by Iran. And so, it wouldn't actually be
hard for those jet-powered drones to
transit down the river through the
Caspian Sea to Iran, and then Iran could
use those against the United States in
the Strait of Hormuz.
I've actually got sort of a a written
comparison right here.
Uh
the Shahed 136, you're looking at, you
know, about uh the low 100s of miles per
hour. These are kilometers per hour
right here. Uh and then closer to about
three times that uh for the jet-powered
Kaman 4, which is also a Shahed drone.
Uh although these are expected to use
Chinese jet engines. So, they put a
small Chinese jet engine on it, which
Kratos thinks one of the biggest growth
verticals they're going to have is jet
engines. Now, let me just be
transparent. I don't have any exposure
to the defense contractors or Kratos.
So, I'm not trying to like shill the
stock cuz like I'm investing in
We're just looking at this now and and
studying this and we find this very
interesting. So, uh interceptor drones
uh cost about thousand bucks
uh over uh in in Ukraine and they can do
a lot of damage with these
thousand-dollar drones. So, your
intercept costs have to really come down
to well below the cost of manufacturing
those drones to actually be competitive.
And you need to be fast enough to take
down these jet drones. Uh and that's the
problem. These
Kaman 4s are not really catchable
drones. They're just too fast. Uh and so
that creates an issue and that's where
Kratos is like, "We might be working on
a potential solution." Now, of course,
there are many military defense
contractors for this. And Karp is
obviously throwing his money into the
military industrial complex on the
startup side. A, probably because he has
access to these private companies. Uh
and B, because, you know, Palantir keeps
how important they are and their AI
system is to
the war against Iran, but also the war
against Russia and Ukraine.
Palantir is taking both sides of that.
Uh well, you know, the Ukrainian side
and the US side. Uh and obviously the
Israeli side.
Uh Kratos, speaking of Israelis, just
acquired a company that was an Israeli
company called Orbit Technologies
Limited. And they are a SATCOMs for
drones companies uh for UAVs but also
for missiles. They specifically say,
"Leading global provider of mission
critical critical satellite-based
communications for mobile and unmanned
aerial, seaborn, undersea, and land
systems as well as other systems." Other
systems are probably like rockets.
So, if we look at the earnings call for
Kratos, there's some really interesting
things that they talk about here.
Let's close all these little sidebars
out here as much as we can. I'll leave
the bookmarks open.
Uh so, this is the directed energy side
and they have a $150 million contract
for counter
uh unmanned aerial vehicles or systems
called the as part of the solar
shield program.
Uh this is where we talked about the
various different ways that you could
defend against a drone. Keep in mind,
there's also the uh US-based sort of
more police department-based company
called Axon that uses Dedrone
technology. They bought a company called
Dedrone.
But, that's not really the subject of
this video.
So, if I now just jump into
some of the hints that Kratos gives.
Look at this. An analyst asks about
unmanned systems and guidance on these
unmanned drone systems. And the
president and CEO says the following,
"We have to be very careful here because
of the customer.
So, we can't get into too much detail on
this because then it will give away what
we're doing.
Our hypersonics business, the engine
business basically, and the space
business, those businesses are ripping.
But, on the
on the drone side, we're going to be
very cautious and we not may not be able
to report it until we ship it and it
shows up in the numbers. And even then,
we may not be able to say much about it,
but you're going to know what it is."
This is a really big nudge nudge wink
wink that over the next year Kratos is
really expected to take explode their
deliveries of drone either weapons or
Valkyries or um
engine systems to help enable bombing
campaigns
or otherwise. Keep in mind, there's
constantly been this talk about the
United States being critically low on
ammunitions after the Iran war.
These right here are examples of Boeing
uh JDAMs
LR, long range.
These JDAMs get fueled by a turbofan,
which is basically a jet engine.
And take a look at this.
Kratos recently
uh Kratos is providing Spartan J85
engines. Those are their turbofan
engines that they produce to support
Boeing's JDAM production contract. So,
in other words, Boeing is hitting up
Kratos saying, "Hey, can you guys help
supply
these jet engines for our missile
program, basically, with the Department
of Defense?"
Now, Kratos is a very small company,
less than $10 billion company.
But here's the Spartan Spartan line of
jet engine. That's kind of what it looks
like. Kind of looks like a bathroom fan
that you put in your bathroom, you know,
like the fart fans.
Uh and then over here
a little bit less of a fart fan and more
of like a jet engine look. This is uh a
jet engine for cruise missiles,
collaborative combat type aircrafts, and
other unmanned aerial vehicles.
They also produce the uh the Valkyrie
aircraft.
That's somewhere in here. I think I
believe that's this. This is under their
their air, but I believe this is the
Valkyrie, but I'm not sure.
But anyway, they've got a Valkyrie
uh aircraft system. Uh oh, here it is.
It's the XQ-58 Alpha.
Yeah, yeah, okay, it was the Valkyrie.
That was the Valkyrie. The Valkyrie,
these things trade for somewhere between
3 to 10 million dollars a piece.
And what I think is really interesting
about the Kratos numbers
is that if you just look
at Valkyrie production alone, right
here,
they think they can get to about 40 of
these produced per year.
If I assume a sort of midpoint of $6
million
per Valkyrie, 40 per year times 6
million would be $240 million
of annual potential revenue. That's
annual potential revenue.
Uh they only produced about $5.9 million
Valkyrie revenue
uh
last quarter. So, very, very small
portion of their business.
Uh their product sales right now sit at
about 237 per quarter.
So, that alone would potentially double
their quarterly revenue uh or or a
quarter's product revenue. So, let me
just draw that out to be really clear to
not be confusing. 200, you know, 40-ish
mill,
roughly what they make from products
in one quarter right now.
A full year of 240 million Valkyrie
sales would basically,
you know, double one quarter or add 25%,
you know, to their product side per
year. It's interesting stat, interesting
way to think about it. But, this is sort
of like a smaller call option in the
business. Where they really seem to make
a lot of money right now is on the
Spartan engine. They call it one of the
single largest opportunities with tens
of thousands of those systems expected
to be sold. Right now, we're planning
initial orders of 3,000 Spartan turbo
jet engines.
We expect to produce an additional 5,000
in 2028. Each of them worth about
$50,000.
So, if you do 5,000 in 2028 at uh 50,000
of them,
uh
that little calculator I was using does
not have enough zeros for this. 5,000
times 50, that puts me at
this number. 1 2 3 200 That's another
250 million right there, just from the
jet engines. So, you really have growth
verticals coming from not just these jet
engines,
not just the Valkyrie UAV, but then also
the de-droning technology, which they're
like nudge nudge hint hint hint we can't
really tell you about it right now, but
you'll see it in our numbers.
Interestingly, much like how Elon Musk
is talking about getting into making
components for jet engines. For Elon's
purposes, those would be turbine gas
engines uh to run continuously to power
data centers. Here, Kratos has a Blade
Works facility in Oklahoma where they've
recently broken ground to help produce
these turbo fans.
Their hypersonics business is on pace to
double from 2025 to 2026.
And they expect their Kratos engine
business to be the largest and fastest
growing
in the company's history.
So, that's their expectation, especially
since uh China and Russia are going deep
on hypersonic missiles. And remember
what we have right here.
China supplying jet engines for those
jet engine drones that Russia is using
against Ukraine.
Big business.
So, here's a small market cap company
that's doing exactly this sort of
vertical of information of of product.
Here's the problem. They have negative
free cash flow. We're expecting
somewhere around negative 100 million
dollars of cash flow per year on
average, though this quarter they were
sitting at about negative 47 already.
That's a lot, so it might even be more.
Forecast negative free cash flow is
negative 95 million. It might be more
than that. Their balance sheet is okay
now because they raised a bunch of
money. They issued a bunch of stock,
they raised a bunch of money, so they
have about a billion bucks free of free
cash flow. 1 billion of free cash flow.
So, if you take 200 mil of CapEx per
year, they have 5 years of CapEx budget,
basically. So, that's pretty good. You
know, they've they've got a decent
balance sheet, low on the long-term debt
side.
Revenue growth, overall growing about
22.8%.
I've got gross profit coming up about
21% suggesting that their margins are
relatively stable.
We have got the carp information, and
then here's the problem, valuation.
Valuation of the company is a little bit
rich right now. It at at the future
margins, the net margins they expect, I
mean, their net margin right here is
shamefully low. Their net income is 11.9
/ 371. Net margin 3.2% right now. So,
forecast margins put them at close to 12
to 13%. That really means they justify
about a 1.3 PEG.
So, they are expensive. They are not
cheap.
You can
I mean, right now they're trading for
software multiples. So, if we pull up
the
Stock AI tool, we're going to see that
right now the Stock AI tool is telling
us this company is on the more expensive
side. So, here's how we're going to do
this. We're going to open up the
Reinvest Terminal app.
And you can see we got the little
terminal tab activated at the top right
there. We're going to type in Kratos.
And we can see here the balance sheet is
rated heavily.
I would agree with that. Pricing power,
margins are stable, so it's pretty
neutral there. Moving average, the stock
has come down a little bit. But the
valuation is really high, so we have a
red flag on valuation. So, we're going
to expect that it's actually going to
say you have a negative forecast rate of
return here. So, when we open this up,
sure enough, there it is, -62% potential
forecast on the stock price. That's
bringing it down to a fair valuation for
the company. Right now, it's very
pricey. And it's gone through one heck
of a a move here. Let's go zoom out for
a moment on the week chart. Take a look
at that explosion that it had. It really
meme rallied.
And they raised money during the meme
rally, which was perfect.
Beautiful. Raise money from the meme
squeeze.
But now they're coming back down to
reality. And uh frankly, this could be a
buy if it came down to about 24 bucks.
Uh because that would be a technical
retracement.
And it would really closely align with
the fair value estimate that the stock
tab has for this company. Uh now, if you
scroll down through this company, you
can actually automatically see a lot of
the information that we have. This is a
Meet Kevin app.
Uh you can see a lot of the information
here, such as that doubling of the
hypersonic business to potentially over
700 million, almost to double again next
year, the unit economics on the jet
engine. A lot of this that, you know, we
manually research is is already just
built into this, which is really
phenomenal. This is a a cool product
that Reinvest, my startup, is is
building.
Uh so, we're very very excited about it.
But
this
to me
this sort of defense side of stock
investing isn't going anywhere anytime
soon, mostly because
the world is unfortunately
remilitarizing.
And I hate saying it, but I think the
way you have to put this together is you
have to put this together as uh you've
got
over here
You got the US, okay?
Then
you've got uh Europe
and NATO.
Europe and NATO, and then you also have
Canada up here, okay? Europe and Canada,
they don't trust America under Donald
Trump. This is obvious. Okay?
So, there's a wall between the US and
the ally Canada. There's a wall between
Europe and Canada uh or Europe and NATO
and then the United States.
That's exactly what Russia wants.
All right? Russia can take advantage of
this and so can China, especially if
we're critically low on munitions. You
know, we got to pump pump pump. We got
to print more money and spend more money
on defense.
And then you've got Russia,
North Korea,
Iran,
and China.
And do you think they are bickering with
each other?
Is China terrifying Russia?
Is Iran making fun of North Korea or
China with memes or calling them morons
or whatever?
No.
These guys
are getting stronger.
And that's where Germany, uh for
example, is now like, "Yo, what the F?
We got Russian drones, Russian attack
drone drones showing up in Germany."
So, really what you have
is this
well, disaster, A. But B, what you
really have is you have Europe going,
"Oh my gosh, we need to spend more money
on defense."
You got Canada going, "I need to spend
some more money on defense. We might be
a little geopolitically like isolated in
terms of region." You know, you have
Greenland. I didn't even mention them.
Greenland,
uh for whatever that's still worth
talking about um
uh some more some more military funding
along with Denmark.
Obviously, the United States has to blow
more money into re-supplying all the
munitions munitions we blew.
And then, of course, all of these guys
over here are re-arming, especially
since the IAEA just came out and said,
"Oh, we have no idea
like we what's going on with Iran's
nuclear program. We have not had access
to their nuclear facilities or their now
fourth announced nuclear enrichment
facility in Esfahan
uh or period Pyramid Mountain.
We don't have access to this. We don't
have color on what's going on with their
nuclear program. We don't know where
their nukes are. So, now you have
nuclear proliferation where other
countries are like, "Oh, let's get into
having our own nukes, too." Plus a
re-militarization
of the world.
And then, there's Kratos, a little $9
billion startup making engines for bombs
and drones.
Too happy, Kevin. Too happy. No, I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not associated with
Kratos.
Uh not paid by Kratos. I'm not investing
in Kratos.
Uh war sucks.
Uh I hate all of it.
But, the reality is this is what's
happening.
Is the world is re-arming and the
defense contractors are going to get
a good chunk of dollahollas for helping
re-arm the world.
>> Why not advertise these things that you
told us here? I feel like nobody else
knows about this.
>> We'll We'll try a little advertising and
see how it goes.
>> Congratulations, man. You have done so
much. People love you. People look up to
you.
>> Kevin Paffrath there, financial analyst
>> [music]
>> and YouTuber Meet Kevin. Always great to
get your take.